Her low freak bitches.
And before I forget,
the reason I wanted to show that video was I got you something.
This is Leo,
may his wife.
So you have the,
you have the,
the knife from Leo May,
his wife made you this right here.
And so because from our second GRE episode I believe,
uh,
we funded a water well there in Bofi and so,
she's really talented.
Um,
I mean it might not look like too much here,
but uh,
that's cool.
What does that mean?
It's bark cloth.
So it's a tree bark cloth.
And when they take the bark off the trees,
fine.
But the a that used to be what?
They would make their clothing out of their clothing.
They would make other materials out of them.
Uh,
they can make these little kind of carrying cases or backpacks kind of out of
it.
They treat it with something like,
how do they get it so soft?
They pound it down.
And I haven't seen the whole process,
but I've seen the bark and where they pull it off and then they kind of beat it
down and beat it down until it's this like cloth.
I know that this right here when I've been doing research,
they have those pygmy,
uh,
boothy pygmy paintings that are made out of bark cloth at Lake,
our National Museum of history in New York.
Um,
they have a few of these there and so it's Kinda cool to see.
I Dunno.
I just was,
uh,
was excited to bring it back to you
said painting and um,
it's,
it's Mama Leo May and she's,
uh,
she's painting it for Esl.
That's awesome man.
Thank you.
Thank her.
Please.
I will.
That's so cool.
How will they just have,
when I go back sometimes they're like,
hey,
well that's you're making it there.
I think your friends.
Yeah.
So that one's not the same one.
I actually didn't think to or I didn't get picture of it whenever she was
picking this one,
but I got a picture of her doing some other ones.
That's Mama's Yz and uh,
she's pretty great at it as well.
And,
um,
so they just,
uh,
yeah,
I mean that's a little bowl we'll leafs this paint that you actually have there
was,
they had some leftover black paint,
but sometimes on that other photo they just use like cassava or berries and they
beat it up a pound it down and make this paint out of it,
but it kind of fades over time.
So this one's one where,
yeah,
that's,
that's it right there where they just pound up this stuff and it's part of their
culture.
It's what they love to do.
They kind of how he saw Leo may pass them down,
uh,
you know,
the farming and that video was actually San g over here from the hand print
that,
yeah,
he got his grandson.
Um,
and this is what the women pass down to their girls is how to make the spark
cloth and how to,
um,
how to paint.
So it's pretty neat.
Their culture,
like they just do everything together.
They rally around each other,
they're happy together,
they sing,
they dance,
but they also suffer together.
If one person in the community is lost,
even for instance,
uh,
it might sound weird in our culture,
but let's say a mother passes away who's like,
she's breastfeeding,
right?
And she passes,
but the baby survives.
Some other woman in the village will take the baby up and start taking care of
that little one.
And,
um,
there is an adoption in the pygmy culture.
Like you,
no one,
no one needs to be adopted because the community rallies around them when
someone's lost,
they all mourned the death together,
but then they rally around that family and see how they can all help and put in.
So it's pretty cool.
I love it.
I've,
I've learned a lot from him was that's how people used to be,
man.
That's,
that's the original sort of tribal life of human beings.
They,
they would all raise each other.
Christopher Ryan had this whole,
um,
uh,
take on it in sex at dawn,
you know,
and,
and Mckenna had a take on it as well.
Uh,
where they were talking about these ancient cultures.
They,
because of the small groups of people,
they were much closer.
They knew everyone in the community,
it was intensely important.
And that there's a lot of people that think that some of the problems that we
deal with today in society are because of this,
this association that we have with our neighbors.
And we don't have a real sense of community.
I mean,
I know like two or three of my neighbors and I see them once a year and I say,
hi,
wave,
how's everything man?
Everything cool?
All right,
good seeing Ya.
But that's it.
You know,
there's no real community,
there's no interaction.
There's no,
there's certainly no contribution as far as like working together together,
food or water or anything like that.
And I would imagine that these people were,
it just intensely close.
Yeah,
absolutely mean that must have been a big part of the attraction to you,
to them.
Like when they took you in and you were living with them and,
yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
I think the average,
my booty pygmy village is only 85 250 on our 10 villages that we help and have
the 3000 acres of land.
Um,
it's over 300,
uh,
for rich each village.
Um,
do you know about Dunbar's number?
Dunbar's number is a number that,
I mean it varies,
but the number,
somewhere around one 50 for most people,
there's a number of people that you can keep close relationships with.
Oh Wow.
They really only have room for 150 people in your head.
You essentially of hard drive space.
Wow.
Yeah.
And that seems to be related to ancient tribal communities that people sense
that we developed that way,
that we develop these,
these small groups of 50 to 150 plus people.
And then when you get larger than that,
things get weird.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
that's,
that's so true.
Like I,
whenever I went through the six year battle with oxy and just,
uh,
narcotics or pain pills,
like I,
um,
I dunno,
I would always be able to isolate super easy,
right?
Because when you're in your home,
you're completely alone.
Um,
and so it's different when you're in a village and with the pygmies,
you saw some of those huts,
how,
how small they are,
you know,
seriously.
In several of them.
Whenever I'm sleeping,
I have to sleep in the center and I have to have my feet out the door.
Um,
because it's so small.
Uh,
but it's,
um,
the only go in there when you're going to or if you're not feeling good and you
need some rest or if the sun's right over your head and in your hot.
Um,
but besides that,
you're cooking your kitchens outside.
Um,
that's where the people is.
That's where you do life is outside of your home.
Uh,
around the campfire.
We call it campfire university because that's where we've been taken to school
from the,
from the pygmies.
Uh,
they,
it's where they teach us the most about life is around the campfire,
learning their culture,
learning about their kids,
learning about the hunts,
learning about how they make this,
make that,
um,
and it's where you get to do life together.
And so it's something really,
really cool.
Honestly,
I told them they want to know bill a little bit about my life.
And I told him that I went through drug addiction for six years and you know,
they don't really struggle with that at all.
And,
uh,
and then I told them I got really depressed and I told him I really sad and I
told him that I got so sad that I decided one time to take as many pills as I
could and drink.
Uh,
there's like half a bottle of Everclear or more,
um,
and snorted a bunch of coke and just wanted to end it all.
So,
I mean,
I told him that I was suicidal and um,
I can't,
I won't ever forget how they,
how they looked at me almost dumbfounded in a way of like,
and then,
and then one of the questions the chief asked me said,
well,
wouldn't hurting you.
You're set.
Wouldn't hurting yourself,
only hurt you.
And,
uh,
so the whole concept of,
I guess what I'm getting to is they had never heard of anyone killing
themselves.
Like,
maybe they had heard stories or something like that,
but they have never known anybody that actually killed themselves or heard of
it.
It's not something that they,
or their community,
their culture,
the pygmies kind of untouched out in the forest or even not a up in the cities.
Like that's just something that they don't struggle with.
They're,
they're struggling so much day in and day out with struggles that are so deep
and they see their family and they do life together.
That I think they just have so much more of.
W W we were just talking about it so much more of a support system.
People that were rally around them.
When you lose a family member,
everyone rallies around you.
Like whenever I go to the funerals,
it's the,
it's the worst thing in the world.
The sounds like people don't try to compose themselves.
They don't try to dress the body real nice and have flowers all around and now,
now losing loss of life is always tough,
always terrible.
Um,
but there's something we do here in our culture where we make it,
um,
try to make it as,
as nice or smooth or almost pretty as possible.
You know,
the person's dressed really nice and it has the flowers and you compose yourself
to come there.
You gather yourself,
you prepare the eulogy,
there's a,
there's a program.
When you step in there,
people get handed something and you know what's going to happen there.
So you kind of can all compose,
man,
they are just so ugly.
It's so raw.
It's so real.
And it's so like in your face and it just rips your heart open to where people
are mourning.
I,
I saw Jayla,
um,
whenever Babo I was the one,
me and Ben were the ones that told [inaudible] he's the chief,
um,
about his grandson passing away.
We were there when it happened.
He wasn't around,
he was out collecting or gathering.
Um,
and we met on the same path together and he saw it in our face that he knew Baba
was sick,
but now he knew that he was gone.
And I remember Jay the wall just falling on his back into this,
off the side of the foot path into like this pile of brush,
like a,
like,
like probably two,
three foot tall where he likes sunk into it and he was just squirming on his
back,
you know,
he's like in his sixties and he's watched so many of his grandchildren like pass
just because they don't have clean water and seeing them squirming,
almost wanting to like crawl out of his skin,
you know?
Um,
and so,
but I don't know.
I don't want to be a bummer.
I,
I'm,
I'm just,
uh,
I'll just express yourself.
It's,
it's,
but then how the whole community,
all hundred and 50,
200,
300 people that were there,
uh,
all mourned together.
Like we shared it.
Like,
I,
I cried in a way that was like,
you know,
like,
like wiping my tears with everybody because everyone,
everyone was morning,
everyone was crying.
It wasn't just a few people.
It wasn't just his mom and his dad,
his mom,
macho it.
W it wasn't just [inaudible],
it was the whole village cried together.
And so I don't know,
but for me that,
that makes it seem like,
I don't know if this,
I don't want to make too many connections between our culture because they're
completely different or a lot different,
but I think here of huge cause of divorce is the loss of a child.
Um,
but there it's almost unites the parents.
so much so whenever they lose a little one.
And I don't,
I don't mean to make this comparison,
but it's like,
I think it's because when they mourn,
they truly go to the depths of the darkest place and they're able to truly
almost get it out,
if that makes sense.
Where when you're at the funeral,
you let yourself go.
You just let go and,
and,
and it's okay,
however ugly or however you handle it,
whatever emotions come,
you just ride that wave,
if that makes sense.
Do you think that because their life is so difficult,
that life itself becomes more precious and the loss becomes more powerful or
more intense?
More,
more raw?
Wow.
Yeah.
I needed you to,
to sum that up for sure.
Um,
yes,
I do.
I think whenever you struggle so much,
your,
you become so much more appreciative and grateful of life,
of every breath you take.
Um,
that's gotta be connected to their lack of understanding suicide because our,
you know,
our idea of what a difficult life is,
it's difficult,
but there's food and shelter and this,
you know,
and really the easiest place to live in the world,
all those things connected.
Whereas with them just staying alive is such a struggle.
And getting water,
which is so easy for us all,
we,
anybody can walk into any bathroom and any gas stop,
turn the water on.
Water comes out.
I mean,
everyone waters on hard to get in America.
And even with the droughts,
it's easy to get water.
We water fucking golf courses with millions of gallons of water every day.
Our understanding of what a struggle is is so different.
And I think whenever we,
when we've really struggle here,
we can go hide away and we don't have to deal with it.
You don't have to have conversations about it.
Um,
we can,
we can almost escape it.
We can escape it with our,
with our toys,
with our technology,
you know,
we can,
we can just bury your face in our phone or a computer or sit and watch a movie.
And like,
whenever those uncomfortable feelings come up,
we can try to ignore them or suppress them,
if that makes sense.
And they're there.
So it's almost,
man,
this is going to be a weird,
strange curve ball or left turn.
But it's almost like a,
I've started floating recently and whenever I go in there,
um,
into the tank,
it's like you have to,
you're,
you're left alone to your thoughts,
right?
You don't have that technology.
You don't have this.
And so you can deal with stuff and you can try to focus and let go.
And,
and for me,
it's been really beneficial.
And so I don't,
I know that sounds weird for me to make that connection,
but,
uh,
but whenever you're just left alone with your own thoughts,
you can go deep.
And I feel like our culture here,
well,
okay,
if we compare,
and I love our culture,
there's,
I'm not saying there's so much wrong with it,
but uh,
but I feel like they're in relationships.
You go an inch or two wide and you go a mile deep in the Congo,
you get to know people and then hear,
a lot of times you go a mile wide,
but you go only,
you only scratched the surface.
You don't go beneath the top soil that much.
Um,
so you do sometimes with,
with a few people,
um,
there's only few people that we trust with that,
you know,
but it's almost like they're,
everyone's so open to,
um,
to go in deep with one another.
And because of that,
you get to know each other better.
You get to a truly hurt when they hurt,
you get to laugh.
When they laugh,
you get to cry when they cry.
Um,
and I may not,
I don't have to keep going on about it,
but please listen to,
don't apologize.
There's a real,
there's a real argument for the way that we live right now is not a way that we
were designed for.
Meaning that,
not that it can't be sustainable or manageable and you can't figure out a way to
live a harmonious life in the modern context,
but that a lot of people think that we're just,
we would naturally fit right in,
in a tribal environment that it would feel natural.
And a lot of people experience that when they go camping for long stretches of
time when they're out in the woods together,
you know,
for whatever reason.
And they just decided to find a place and live off the land.
I mean,
that's why I think a lot of those shows like those um,
subsistence living shows like,
um,
the homesteading.
Yeah,
that's very good.
It's a very attractive to people because I think there's a longing in our,
our DNA eve and where it just,
there's a pole,
there's a pull to that man.
I would love to just grow Kale and raise chickens and live off the farm.
So a lot of people that feel like really,
really attracted to that.
And I think it's,
it's something deep in our being that we're longing for this connection to the
real world and we've done an amazing thing creating cities.
It's dependence.
It's some,
it's almost beyond our comprehension because we're a part of it.
You know,
we're a part of it.
It's normal.
You get on the subway,
you get in your car,
you drive through the city seems normal.
But it's so far removed from every single aspect of our history.
I mean,
this is so new.
It's so recent.
I think these people are just more in tune.
It's horrible that they have to deal with these situations.
The lack of water and toilets and the diseases and all the,
the,
the other struggle.
But man,
and there's a part of what they're doing and the way they're living that just
seems like they're more in tune in a natural way.
Yeah.
Right.
You would think that they would be more depressed.
And,
uh,
but,
but like,
you heard,
you heard Leo May's laugh in that when they asked him about the bananas and he
just got tickled,
you know,
he couldn't,
couldn't hold himself from just laughing and saying,
I can't count that much.
Someone from Beverly Hills and say,
Hey,
this is what we got for a cause.
You can grow bananas now.
Like,
fuck you.
How do I get Outta here?
Firstclass only,
you know?
Right.
Where's my iPhone?
Yeah,
yeah.